all these balloons that you've seen
floating over the United States that's
part of their information gathering
process to execute their unrestricted
Warfare techniques the only thing
holding them back is the fact that that
we're their Cash Cow where the tit they
suck on right we're we're it we're Uncle
sucker and and the way they lifted 250
million peasants at least up into
statuses sweatshops was by running big
trade surpluses with the United States
it goes on and on and on I just I wrote
this in 2006 it reads like a pentagon
report today and we all we get is all we
get is rhetoric and so BS from the
corporate media and the Congress